Malcolm got me a little French Bulldog
and my dog was most steps if you held a
ball you could hold the ball and the dog
would stare at the ball all day long and
that's the kind of focus that Stanley
Kubrick had like a French Bulldog in a
ball that's so true that's so true
Stanley gave me this puppy dog was a
golden retriever it was a most charming
thing he did you know the dog the house
dog had a litter and he said you know
you get to pick you know it really Stan
it's very sweet so I picked one and the
next day said what do you call what do
you call the dog I said I called it Alex
he went Alex why Alex I went what do you
mean why Alex I'm playing Alex he goes
why didn't you call it Stanley I said
because Stanley
I'd be going around the set going
Stanley get over here a friend of mine
told me about Stanley Kubrick's
photography background he gave me an old
Rolleiflex camera and he said you should
learn how to use a show up on the set
with it and it would break the ice
should be a way to become friends with
Stanley Kubrick so I started teaching
myself to use this beautiful old twin
lens reflex camera medium format camera
beautiful and I showed up on the set
with it around my neck
and I was kind of wanting Stanley to say
something about my camera and and
finally he got really annoys what are
you doing with it what are you doing
with that old piece of [ __ ] camera and I
I say Schneider pieces a beautiful
camera cos now listen if you want to
take pictures on my set this is what you
do you go out and you buy this and of
course knew all about the best
technology was available yeah he told me
every single lens to buy it was a
Minolta camera all the way down to the
camera bag and I hated it
but I love this Rolleiflex well that's
probably why you're an actor and he was
one of the great direct that's right
that's right but he extraordinarily
allowed me to take pictures with my
Rolleiflex on the set I kept it in my
flak jacket and they came
useful when you were doing your diary
that's it yeah that's all I wanted to do
is publish the photographs and then the
guy said you're going to have to tell a
story about these pictures and I said
well I kept a diary and he said well
transcribe it and then when we
transcribed it we realized that there
was an extraordinary story about the
Wizard of Oz about the man behind the
curtain
yeah that there's this story about this
extraordinary genius that we all we talk
about his black eyes all night tonight
they really were black and powerful and
Pierce intelligent intelligent deeply
deeply intelligent and this these
extraordinary stories they got they got
created about him some of them true some
of them not true keep he becomes like
the the Powerful oz this this image of
Stanley Kubrick like the the in The
Wizard of Oz that projected onto our
consciousness was really just a mensch
II Jewish kid from the Bronx well the
wonderful lee ermey who plays the drill
instructor in the first half of the film
was in a car accident really and a
steering wheel broke his broke his ribs
he wasn't hired to be the drill
instructor in the film he was hired to
be the the the person who I know yeah
teaches you how to March the technical
adviser on the film and he was teaching
one of the actors to do it yeah yeah and
what auditioning actually story you know
but he he was so he ends up getting the
role and he was really nervous because
he couldn't memorize lines and and the
great Leon Vitali who who Ryan worked
with and he played Lord Bullington is
the grown-up who shoots you and makes
you lose your leg
Leon Vitali was working with our Lee
army night and day to get him to
memorize those lines and how did he do
he did unbelievably but Lee had this
nervous smell and that would come up
from his gut and come out of his mouth
and he was a chain smoker and he drank
copious amounts of coffee so people
would say like how was it when he would
get in your face and yell was really
hard to act with him and it was like
you're right it was hard to act with him
he had the worst if his his breath
smelled like the like one of the alleys
in downtown Los Angeles on Skid Row